welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka the guy who has a
sith sense when it comes to spotting
easter eggs the first trailer for the
book of boba is now here and throughout
this video we're going to be breaking it
down pointing out all the things you
missed and also giving our theories on
where this story could be going full
spoilers ahead for everything so far and
i'll also be talking about elements of
the bad batch so if you haven't had a
chance to check it out then i highly
recommend that you check out now yoda
man if you liked the video and make sure
you subscribe to the channel as we are
going to be covering the show weekly
when it releases without the way thank
you for clicking this now let's get into
the book of boba
okay so the mandalorian season two sort
of filled us in on exactly what happened
after boba fett got up close and
personal with the sarlacc after escaping
the 1000 years of digestion that he
would have been subjected to fat remain
on tatooine his armor was taken by koban
banth refrigeration and afro got handed
over to mandel fair ended up partnering
with fenix shan to help him stop moff
gideon's forces episode 8 of season 2
ended with that returning to jabba's
palace and after killing bib fortuna he
took over the throne with shan by his
side it takes two to django and it was
an awesome way to end the season that
sort of teased exactly what was gonna
happen in this one now in the bad batch
we learned that much in the same way
that boba was the alpha clone of django
that his sister omega was well the omega
she was the first clone to be assigned
to a different gender and it is possible
that she will be showing up in the
series as she will be the same age as
fed is now all of the titles for the
episodes were leaked earlier in the year
and much like the mandalorian they will
be divided up into chapters
interestingly book of boba will
apparently start at chapter 17 which
means that it's going to be a direct
continuation of the mandalorian the
episode titles are called the champion
the assassin the syndicate the
battleground the homeworld the warlord
the showdown and the hunter so by the
sounds of it vet will basically be
coming across different characters every
episode similar to the setup that we had
in the mandalorian now we start off the
trailer with the cavernous rocks outside
of jabba's palace and we see the
beaumont or spider which could be
spotted in the back of return of the
jedi these were originally a group known
as the beaumont monks who believed that
in order to achieve enlightenment that
they had to transform themselves into
something that would completely isolate
their minds they had their brains put
into jars and used these spider-like
droids in order to move around we then
hear fett state that he's not a bounty
hunter and this is questioned by a
voice-over who says that they've heard
otherwise the voice states that he knows
he sits on the throne of his former
employer and this is clearly a reference
to him taking jabbers now throughout the
trailer it is said that jabber ruled
with fear whereas fed rules with respect
it's clear that he knows that if
everyone is scared of him that they
might try and overthrow him so he's
trying a different approach which
involves cooperation fetis passed his
helmet by a droid and we then cut to him
and fennec walking through the streets
and she is suited up with her helmet
that we of course saw in the mandalorian
and also the bad batch now according to
the leaks at some point in the season
that will be hunting a rancor the one in
the return of the jedi died so we know
that is in that one yes spoilers for
that it is in that one however the bad
batch featured a rancor called muchi
which could indeed be the one that the
episode sent us around the one in the
return of the jedi was called batisa and
though we never had it confirmed it was
thought that moochie could be its child
this is because at the end of episode
five of the bad batch bib fortuna came
to pick muchi up and thus everyone kind
of took it that they were related now
that does mean that muchi could have
been at jabba's palace and then have
escaped which would set up the episode
that we'll apparently be seeing in the
show now whether this is that moment we
don't know but it does sort of line up
with the leaks though it might be
completely disconnected now we then
catching i thorian and this very much
sets up the idea that fett is visiting
several different factions and species
in order to form an alliance now the
syndicate episode is likely centered
around one of the syndicates in star
wars canon yes spoilers for that too now
these include crimson dawn the black
zone the cremora syndicate hut clan and
the pike syndicate all are as bad as
each other and if you want to negotiate
the underworld of the star wars galaxy
then these are the people that you're
gonna have to go toe to toe with at some
point now from what we see in the
trailer i'm not 100 whether fat will be
coming face to face with the classic
ones but it is possible that the
syndicates are very much the ones that
we see him having dinner with shan says
that they were all once captains under
jabber but it is possible that they lost
this control under bib and this is sort
of why everything fell apart perhaps
they lost their positions after leia
killed him and since then they haven't
had the ability to lay a finger on the
power setup of tatooine now amongst
these we see a set of aqualish who are
the same species that ponder baba was at
the table we can also catch some
tranductions which are the same species
as bosk i'd absolutely love to see bosk
in this series and though i don't think
that this is him it would make for a
really cool call back to the original
saga now we see that life isn't easy for
fete and there are two brand new
characters that point guns at him in the
background we can catch the gomorian
gods who then join him at the dinner
table and it's like that he inherited
these after taking over jabba's palace
we also see some tuscan raiders
sorry sand people wait wait is it tuscan
raiders no i'm not being racist we see
them walking in the desert and the
mandalorian very much showed that they
could be allies which lends itself to
the idea that fett is building an order
we can also catch some tweel x which the
dancer at jabba's palace was it's a nice
imagery to include these as the one at
jabba's was of course sent to her death
whereas here it looks like fed is
actually reaching out to them we then
cut the shots of fat's helmet rolling on
the ground and out of it comes credits
with the rebel alliance logo on them
this is taking place after the return of
the jedi so it makes sense that these
would be here as the rebels are now
running the show but not very well from
what i've heard now the imagery of this
also somewhat recaptures the death of
jango who was beheaded by mace windu and
it shows that fed isn't gonna have an
easy time they are attacked by gods with
shields which look like they're using
the same technology as the ones from the
phantom menace they have a burgundy
uniform on and it could be possible that
they're part of the same group as the
people who draw guns on them earlier in
the trailer now it is difficult to tell
exactly what's going on in this first
look and personally i don't even think
they're actually showing all that much
beyond the first couple of episodes
that's why everything sort of looks like
it's on a sand planet and why it seems
like boba is very much just getting
started now the homeworld episode could
be about phet retaking mandalore he last
left this plot thread in the mandalorian
season 2 episode 3 and it is possible
affair ends up teaming up with bo katan
to take back the planet mandalore was
constantly in the stages of war and it
went from a pretty advanced society to
being a shell of its former self control
of the planet has gone back and forth
throughout the entire star wars saga and
i think it would be great to have
basically go through the series taking
things for himself before he builds back
up to taking mandalore now he's able to
dispatch the guards very quickly and he
busts out some of the moves that we saw
him using in the mandalorian to take
people out it cements that he's brutal
when he needs to be but the trailer also
shows that he has somewhat of a balance
as one of the crime captains vacates the
table to which shan says that jabba
would have killed him for however fett
wants to work with them and it's a
really nice way to close out the trailer
he sits back in his throne looking like
the king and i love how he exudes power
even though he's not being threatening
he's got a very hoth and cold demeanor
and it's a great way to close out this
first teaser
now as for my general reaction and
thought on the trailer i have a really
good feeling about this and the teaser
is a great setup for what's to come it's
just a really grim and gritty feeling to
the entire thing and i love how
authentic it feels to the original
trilogy the mandalorian did an excellent
job of capturing the aesthetic of the
sort of rusty grimy and almost
secondhand feel that the original
trilogy has and this is no different
everything feels kind of lived in and it
looks absolutely incredible boba fett is
one of those characters that was a fan
favorite the moment that he appeared on
screen and i was absolutely fascinated
with him as a kid even though he kind of
went out like a chump and barely did
anything in the original saga he's
always kind of had this allure to him
though and the expanded law very much
helped to cement his legend even if the
main trilogies kind of kept him out the
way when the mandalorian was announced a
lot of people well me i don't know how
you felt it did kind of seem like it
would be a sort of spiritual successor
or rather the fetch show that we should
have got even if all the characters were
different that's why it was so amazing
when disney brought him back and i'm so
happy that we're getting a full tv show
centered around the character and what
he go on to do he's still known as the
galaxy's most fearsome bounty hunter and
this brand new look really knocks out
the park and lets you know that disney
are messing around can't wait to watch
it and the king is back he's back baby i
love this trailer now obviously i'd love
to hear your thoughts on it so make sure
you comment below and let me know
there's a ton to talk about and i'm sure
we missed some easter eggs so make sure
you drop them below if there's any that
you spotted and we didn't as a thank you
we are in competition right now and
giving away three copies of the zack
snyder dc trilogy on the 30th of
november and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the teaser
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now so
that's you then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want to meet us to
watch then make sure you check out
breakdown of all the spiderman norway
home leaks that were posted last week
there's lots of cool things like a first
look at the green goblin costume some
more plot leaks and yeah just a lot of
things to dive into if not then thank
you for sticking through this video i
hope to see you for our mobius trailer
breakdown tomorrow and you take care of
yourself until then you've been the best
i've been paul peace